I took a listening Class A few years ago
I thought I was a great listener and I
realized that I am an absolutely
fantastic listener when I talk to people
I'll never see again for the rest of my
life but absolutely terrible with my
friends and loved ones I would have
these fights with my friends and loved
ones and they'd say you're such a bad
listener and I was like do you know what
I do for a living I'm pretty good turns
out I sucked turns out all my friends
knew I suck too and so I've really
worked very hard at taking the things
that I know about active listening that
I do in a work environment and bringing
it into my personal life I'm learning to
hold space I'm learning to put my
emotions aside and not take things
personally so I can provide a safe space
for somebody to feel heard now when I
have an argument for example I always
fight to get to resolution I used to
fight to be right so yeah I think my
personal listening skills
um I'm really proud I'm really proud
they're a lot better now and I think my
friends would agree